et on revient sur ces mobilisations pro
palestinienne en france avec nos invités
celle des battoirs et nous sommes avec
jacques myard mer les républicains de
maisons laffitte et david guiraud
porte-parole jeunesse de la france
insoumise bonsoir messieurs et merci
d'accepter de participer à cet échange
sur rt france david guiraud une
trentaine d'associations sont donc à
l'origine de l'appel à se mobiliser à
paris et ce qu'elles ont eu raison selon
vous de maintenir l'appel au
rassemblement malgré l'interdiction
écoutez moi déjà je pars d'un constat je
crois que l'heure est assez grave
la france patrie des droits de l'homme
il parlait un est un des seuls pays
peut-être le seul pays démocratique du
moins en occident avoir interdit
aujourd'hui des manifestations en
soutien à la palestine
je vous dis ça parce que à madrid en
espagne il ya eu des manifestations à
sydney en australie aujourd'hui une des
manifestations à londres en
grande-bretagne de grosse grosse
mobilisation il y en a eu à new york à
quelques jours aujourd'hui à bucarest en
roumanie il ya eu des mobilisations
elles se sont bien passées et qu'est ce
qu'on observe aujourd'hui où nous avait
dit qu'il fallait interdire les
manifestations en soutien aux
palestiniens parce qu'il y aurait des
risques de deux porte-parole honte actes
antisémites il y en a eu
je n'ai pas vu un jour peut-être qu'il y
en avait mais moi je n'ai pas vu pour le
coup et il ya aucun média qui fait état
de flamber d'autres d'antisémitisme de
la même manière qu'on ne vous avait dit
qu'il y aurait énormément de violence il
n'y a pas de synagogue qui a été attaqué
pas de commerces qui ont été dévalisés
de chrono de quoi on a interdit cette
mobilisation
moi je rappelle juste que la liberté de
manifester à les garanties par la
constitution
c'est la liberté d'expression c'est la
liberté de conscience et donc quand on
attaque ses libertés fondamentales on
pose un grave coup à la démocratie
aujourd'hui moi je suis indigné par ce
qui s'est passé oui alors l'exécutif
pour justifier sa décision d'interdire
la mobilisation à paris a mis en avant
le risque de débordements comme on les a
vécus en 2014 jacques myard est ce que
vous comprenez à la position du
gouvernement
alors je connais la position david et
les caire que le droit de manifester est
un droit constitutionnel mais aussi
encadré il faut pas croire la
jurisprudence administrative et près
clair c'est que à chaque fois qu'il peut
y avoir des preuves au risque de
débordement il peut y avoir des
contraintes
l'imitation ça c'est la jurisprudence on
aurait évacué ce problème je dirais de
droit pour revenir à la réalité de ce
soir il est exact que cette
manifestation aujourd'hui elle peut se
comprendre
ô combien parce que ce qui se passe au
proche et au moyen-orient
bien sûr en france nous le ressentons
directement nous avons une très grande
communauté de personnes qui sont je
dirais en franchise âge avec la
situation proche et au moyen-orient
que ce soit du côté des français de
confession israélite où que ce soit du
côté des français qui sont en jeu dirait
qu'ils ont une appétence ou un soutien
aux palestiniens
moi je comprends que le gouvernement
voulait éviter des débordements et je
suis d'accord
aujourd'hui il y a eu quelques heures
mais ça s'est relativement bien passée
je n'ai pas entendu et c'est exact david
des propos antisémites 2 soit loué si je
peux me permettre cette expression parce
que je suis agnostique mais ce qui est
certain c'est que en réalité mon je vais
je dire une chose je connais bien cette
région je suis allé dans tous ces pays
j'ai même eu un entretien avec arafat
lorsqu'il était encore en vie et on est
dans une impasse totale
parce que aujourd'hui c'est vrai que ce
conflit revient en actualité mais je
dirais que d'un côté il ya les tirs de
roquettes mais de l'autre il y a la
volonté de certains colons d'expulser
lés palestiniens le gérer gms et ça se
comprend qu'ils réagissent
il ya franchement à chaque fois une
autre auto histoire tu m'as fait sale je
te paie ça et ça repart et donc
aujourd'hui la situation que nous avons
au proche et au moyen-orient et surtout
entre la palestine et israël est une
impasse totale
le plan pour deux états avec une
fédération pour essayer de bien
travailler ensemble s'est éloigné avec
la position de trump qui est criminel
qui est criminel parce que il a
véritablement attiser
je dirais les haines ancestrales c'est
il faut savoir que à gaza c'est horrible
il ya vingt-deux mille 22000 personnes
au kilomètre carré au presse dans les
conditions très difficiles
ensuite israël et gaza et la cisjordanie
ces deux à trois départements français
donc ces deux peuples sur des
territoires extrêmement proches et avec
une politique israélienne de force
je suis le regret de le dire notamment
avec la colonisation
donc si les états du monde ne pèse pas
pour imposer une règle je me souviens
d'une réflexion de de védrines qui
disait un jour tu t'es une crise une
nouvelle fois nous constatons qui serait
la plus influent sur les états unis que
les états unis sur israël est en réalité
il ya un moment il va falloir que les
protagonistes comprennent où ils se font
la guerre d'une manière éternelle où il
commence à vivre en paix et bien je peux
vous dire que le chemin de damas est
encore très long david guiraud bah
écoutez on a un désaccord sur la tenue
de la mobilisation voilà acto le bâton
le moi je moi je trouve ça un pensable
qu'on puisse interdire une mobilisation
parce qu'il ya sept ans une autre
mobilisation qui par ailleurs avait été
aussi interdite avait débordé parce que
moi j'ai vu beaucoup de mobilisation
pour la palestine très bien se passer
je vous rappelle quand même que mercredi
on avait une mobilisation devant
l'assemblée pro palestinienne où le
président de l'association france
palestine solidarité qui est quand même
un modéré parmi les modérés un monsieur
yves rome qui a eu un rendez-vous avec
le ministère des affaires étrangères en
sortant de ce rendez-vous avec le
ministère des affaires étrangères il
s'est fait arrêter
il s'est fait menotter et et a été placé
en garde à vue c'est insupportable c'est
insupportable et donc bon on a on a ce
désaccord là maintenant sur le fond de
la faire effectivement c'est à la
communauté internationale de bouger oui
le dossier difficile mais qu'est ce qui
permet un retour à la paix pour beaucoup
de gens pour la communauté
internationale c'est notamment le retour
aux accords d'oslo c'est à dire que il
fut un temps où y compris des juifs
comme isaac rabin
été assassinés depuis penser que la paix
était possible que les deux parties
devaient faire un choix devait devait
faire un choix douloureux c'est à dire
que les palestiniens devraient devait
accepter de leur côté l'existence de
l'état d'israël
et puis l'état d'israël de son côté
devait accepter que les palestiniens
avaient droit à un territoire à une
autonomie à une souveraineté financière
à l'arrêt du blocus et c est pourquoi
des jeunes aujourd'hui se mobilisent
mais justement pour demander aux états à
la communauté internationale de bouger
s'il ya des mobilisations partout dans
le monde aujourd'hui c'est parce que
c'est notre seul levier d'action et les
gens l'ont bien compris
d'ailleurs vous avez bien vu il n'y a
pas eu de deux slogans rible ça existe
un mois je je je je je condamne
parfaitement les gens qui utilisent de
la cause palestinienne pour vomir leur
antisémitisme mais enfin vous voyez bien
qu'un appât on a une jeunesse
aujourd'hui qui n'a pas connu les
accords d'oslo qui n'a pas connu moi je
moi je fais partie d'une génération
les accords d'oslo c'est dans les livres
d'histoire mais qui aimerait bien que ça
bouge et qui peut faire bouger les
choses sinon la france aujourd'hui
la france elle est coupable de son
inaction je me souviens par exemple d'un
françois mitterrand d'un jacques chirac
c'est-à-dire d'une tradition française
d'une vraie tradition française dans la
diplomatie française à agir pour la
souveraineté des palestiniens
aujourd'hui le processus de colonisation
il s'est accentué vous avez des
organisations de défense des droits
humains comme human right watch qui
accuse l'état d'israël de crime
d'apartheid ce qui n'est quand même pas
rien et l'état français ne fait rien
comme si on peut plus rien faire moi je
crois et la jeunesse de ce monde entier
pense que si les gouvernements du monde
entier se mobilisent il y a moyen de
retourner à la paix pas de manière
facile pas de manière automatique
mais c'est le saint vallier d'action
j'admire votre regard sur la position de
la france et sur la posture d'un
d'emmanuel matheron sur ces tensions et
à et l'oat palestinienne regrette
profondément que la france n'est plus
d'indépendance en politique étrangère
est collé à la position américaine
je le dis comme je le pense la france a
une position particulière dans tous les
pays arabes et elle doit retrouver au
nom de ses propres intérêts au nom de sa
culture
oh non je dirais du de la détermination
des peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes une
politique indépendante
or malheureusement depuis un certain
nombre
de temps elle a collé à la position
américaine
que ce soit en syrie que ce soit avec
l'arabie saoudite
ce que ce soit effectivement jordanie et
en palestine
il est indispensable que la france est
une politique indépendante et passe en
temps de savoir
elle va pas se faire que des amis parce
que c'est pas le rôle d'une politique
étrangère que de vouloir faire les béni
oui oui elle doit acter le fait que
effectivement il faut que les
palestiniens aient un état et que israël
soient en sécurité
bien évidemment parce que de ce côté là
il y à des extrémistes dans les deux
bords on l'a vu d'ailleurs dans les
derniers événements où on a eu des juifs
orthodoxes extrêmement raciste et anti
arabe comme il y à du côté du hamas des
gens qui veulent faire part dont la peau
des juifs
donc ce n'est pas acceptable il faut que
l'on puisse remettre les choses d'aplomb
et qu'on puisse dire
vous êtes deux peuples mais vous vivez
dans la dans le même endroit vous vivez
au proche-orient et il faut qu'on arrive
à imposer des solutions c'est pas facile
je reconnais ça va prendre encore
beaucoup de temps malheureusement les
les accords d'oslo sont maintenant ou
presque mort et enterré
il faut reprendre ce dialogue l'imposer
aux deux parties sinon on n'est parti
que pour une impasse totale et le lierre
qui va durer au bénéfice de personnes
un tout dernier mot avec vous david
biraud l'exécutif français redoute que
ne s'exporte en france ces tensions
israélo-palestiniennes est ce que le
danger est réel selon vous et c'est le
gouvernement qu en train d'exporter le
conflit parce qu'aujourd'hui vous aviez
des mobilisations les mobilisations
autorisées se sont mal passées quelques
les autos les manifestations interdites
aujourd'hui qui se passe mal mais
regardez de toute façon je ont dit ça
pour pour pour le conflit pour ce qui se
passe en israël et en palestine mais en
fait sur les gilet jaune aussi quand
vous regardez sur plein de mobilisation
c'est quand on interdit les
manifestations que ça se passe mal parce
que les gens quoi les gens ils veulent
exercer leur droit de manifester
ils veulent exercer une liberté
fondamentale
donc des fois ça arrive qu'ils des
casseurs mais enfin si on se met à
interdire une mobilisation à chaque fois
qu'il ya un risque de casse on autorise
plus rien je vous le dis est ce qu'il y
ait toujours un et ce sera le mot de la
fin à faire maintenant
malheureusement le beau fils moule le
règlement de l'aco convient pas juste
choses vont aller les histoires oui
pardon c'est que des mouvements
antisémites en france il y en a et on ne
peut pas nier qu'ils cachent toristes
parce que on a bien plus certains
appellent sans que les propos
antisémites sont là et les actes
antisémites sont là donc ils peuvent
également de ce côté là que le
gouvernement soit faite ferme et à cause
la censure terme à toutes ces robes et
touristique tout antisémite mais cela ne
signifie pas qu'on ne puisse pas
critiquer la politique d'israël
merci à tous les peuples sémites
donc je ne sais pas c'est pas la
question du jour merci à tous les deux
mais si on aura l'occasion de reprendre
cet échange merci d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir sur arte france jacques myard
merlin public un de maisons laffitte et
david guiraud porte-parole jeunesse de
la france insoumise